dodging the manchester rainshowers and
the heckling of protesters outside the
security perimeter the british prime
minister would be forgiven for feeling
besieged by circumstance at the moment
but boris johnson is not a self-doubting
kind of person
the ongoing cues at the uk's petrol
pumps he dismissed as being largely
driven by demand rather than a chronic
shortage of delivery drivers and he
insisted the uk's labor shortages would
not be solved by pulling what he
described as the big lever marked
uncontrolled immigration
when people voted for change in 2016 and
when people voted for change again in
2019 as they did they voted for the end
of a broken model of the uk economy that
relied on low wages and low skill and
chronic low productivity and we're
moving away from that the concept of
leveling up is a major theme of this
conference and this government the drive
for equality of opportunity regardless
of background or income and a
redistribution of investment and
infrastructure spending to the regions
but paying for that involves cutting
social benefits and increasing taxes and
several thousand anti-austerity
protesters made their concerns heard as
they marched past the conference venue
well basically this conservative
government are driving people into
poverty at the moment they've taken
millions of people off furlough they're
cutting benefits and they're driving
down wages terms and conditions of
working people in this country
at the heart of boris johnson's argument
to the conference and to the wider
public is the principle of jam tomorrow
yes there will be shortages at the
petrol pumps there may even be shortages
on supermarket shelves leading up to the
crucial christmas period but he says the
uk is in a transition period where it's
moving to a higher wage higher skill
economy
and he says the benefits will soon come
there are doubts even among his
conservative colleagues about the strong
likelihood that more tax risers may be
needed to pay for all this in the 2019
election johnson's party made
spectacular gains in manchester and the
north of england the question is whether
he can win them over again when he gives
his keynote conference speech on
wednesday
paul brennan al jazeera manchester